so brie it's good to see you thank you
for joining us
uh how are you for having me how are you
feeling after um
after the events of last night after the
big show
yeah to be honest i'm feeling a little
bit relieved
i'm feeling relieved um personally that
you know this this has all kind of come
um
full circle and that we can put this
behind us and
begin to move forward yeah have you um
you know you said that it's been kind of
up and down you've had your difficulties
dealing with
uh after the show being uh you know
having been eliminated and
coming out of it um yeah looking back on
everything
what's your overall take on your
experience are you
happy that it all happened do you have
any regrets
um i have no regrets i have no regrets
in terms of how everything all
played out you know i i don't regret
allowing myself to
really open up and really fall for matt
i think there was a lot of lessons that
i could take away from this season and
even just after watching
you know the final special last night i
think that there is a lot that we
could all take away from this season so
i'm excited to see you know what's on
the horizon for
for the show and for everyone that was
involved this season
were you surprised at all with um how
things played out between
matt and rachel
i think i was surprised um i think it i
was surprised because you know i did
think that
matt and rachel were in love but you
know after watching last night that was
the first
time i had seen any of those
conversations take place and
and i get it um i i sympathize with both
of them it has to be really really hard
to kind of come out of something
like this and you know you kind of have
to ask yourself how do you move forward
you know emmanuel did such a good job of
asking so many great questions
um and guiding people through these
conversations how do you think rachel
handled herself in all of this
yeah i'm i'm proud of how she handled
herself throughout all of this you know
speaking for myself being in that
situation in the hot seat with emmanuel
um those were really uncomfortable
conversations and they were hard to have
and i know it's not easy
um and i think she did the best that she
could i think she was
extremely apologetic and i think i
understand where matt is coming
from as well just as a black woman and
you know through my lived experiences
it's
hard to see yourself forward with
someone after those things take place
but
i think given the situation i really
hope that
you know rachel uses this as a learning
lesson to
to move forward and really put actions
behind her words now
yeah we uh introduced some things last
night to new bachelorettes which is
exciting
do you do you see yourself having a
future with the bachelorette franchise
could you come back
you know i i think i personally
it might not be an experience for me
anymore
um i had a great you know once in a
lifetime
opportunity to find love on the show
with matt and
um i'm happy with how it ended and i'm
happy with that
being the end of my experience there you
know you
everybody saw that instagram post where
you're joking about asking for your job
back like
yes quick life update i am polishing up
my resume
okay very good we are polishing up our
resume
what are your thoughts on um caitlyn and
tasia
taking over as hosts i
i'm excited you know while while i did
like chris on the show you know i think
that he
could be a really good catalyst for
change moving forward
and i hoped that this could give an
opportunity
for additional diverse stories to be
heard on the show so i'm extremely
happy that caitlin and tasha get that
opportunity
and i hope you know we can see we can
see more um not just of them but
other additional voices what are your
thoughts
on uh chris harrison maybe coming back
at some point
yeah i think i think given chris's large
prominence on the show
he could really be a good catalyst for
change i think
if he's committed and again you know
takes accountability and starts putting
his words into action
i think a lot of good change could come
out of that
and out of people who are following him
and watching him um
i think that it would be helpful if they
could see that as well
yeah um just a second ago you know you
were talking about the idea of um
finding love moving forward how
difficult it might be to do
such a thing is that on your mind right
now
[Music]
yeah you know i would i would be lying
if i didn't say i didn't think it was
going to be dating i i made a joke and
asked myself how do i go back to normal
dating after an experience
like this you know i'm so used to just
diving straight into deep conversation
um i foresee it being a little bit
challenging but but no i'm excited i
feel like i learned
a lot from my relationship with matt and
from my experience on the show and i'm
just
i'm looking forward to carrying that
into my next relationship going forward
like what kind of dating experiences are
guys going to have to try and
live up to right if they're like taking
a huge
huge dating experiences like i'm
basically gonna ask like
tell me your biggest deepest darkest
secret on the first date and they're
gonna be like oh i don't know it's gonna
work out like you're not on it we're not
on a tv show bree
not anymore so you know you're polishing
up the resume but what do you want to do
next
what's next for you yeah i'm i'm really
open to opportunities
right now um i am definitely considering
going back into
a corporate role and i'm just i'm open
to
exploring other opportunities and where
you know i go
from from the show so excellent
well brie thank you so much for taking
the time to chat with us uh
pleasure watching your journey and good
luck with everything coming up
thank you so much i really appreciate it
you